The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of
MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
And please feel
free to interrupt.
I'd just as soon run this as
a discussion, if you'd like.
Is that permitted, do you know?
MODERATOR: Absolutely.
PROFESSOR: OK, so
these are conflicts
of interests for
those of you who care,
or you can get it in more detail
here by going to this website.
And I thought I will talk
about this topic of causality.
You've learned quite a
bit already in this course
about tools for analyzing
genomes from various aspects,
but what you do after
you analyze it is you
want to test your hypotheses.
And this is a very richly
enabling idea, in the sense
that you can go to very
small cohort sizes,
as we'll see-- N of
one cohort sizes--
and your false positives
are less of a concern
if you have a high throughput
way of testing them.
And so I think
it's very important
to know the possibilities
for testing causality.
And that gets us into
engineering genomes--
and, in a particular, about
computer-aided design.
So you've talked about
computer-aided analysis;
now let's talk about
computer-aided design
of genomes, both
bacterial and human.
So I just want to
illustrate the idea.
You might say, well, why would
we want to design genomes?
You can test
causality, typically,
by changing one base pair.
Why would you want to change
more than one base pair?
If you have a SNP, that's great.
Well, sometimes you have
multiple SNPs interacting
in multigenic-- and we'll
get to humans in a moment.
But here's a radical
example, something
from the extreme
edge, where you'd
want to change almost every
base pair in the genome--
not make a copy of a
genome but actually design,
in an intelligent way--
semi-intelligent--
combinatorial as
well-- a genome that
has new functions,
new properties.
And the four functions I
submit for your consideration
here is that you might
want to be genetically
and metabolically
isolated for safety
reasons or public
relations reasons or both.
You want to have new
chemistry, new protein
chemistry, new amino acids.
And finally, you want to
have multi-virus resistance.
This is probably the most
powerful of the four,
where imagine that you have
an organism-- whether it's
industrial, agricultural,
or even human-- that
was resistant to all viruses,
past and present-- even ones
you haven't analyzed.
So how do we do this?
How do we get new functionality?
How do we design a genome in
such a way that doesn't break?
Because if you change
the genome enough,
you get your comeuppance.
You learn you don't know as
much as you think you know.
You have your beautiful computer
simulations from your analysis,
and as soon as you test them,
you start getting surprises.
So anyway, I'm going to focus
on this process of designing
and building and then testing.
And then, so this
part of the design
has to have an
analytic component.
So we'll get back to your
old friends in analytics.
So as I go down this list, maybe
just show of hands of how many
have been exposed to these
computational tools already.
So Bowtie, anybody?
OK, good.
See, you covered that, so
I don't need to cover that.
Number two-- no?
Some?
SnpEff?
JBrowse-- SQL, you've
all heard of SQL, right?
OK, good.
Let's see.
So the point is
each of these things
is integrated into this system
we call "Millstone," which
is all about design
and analysis.
So it's this loop that goes
around and around, as you'll
see in just a moment--
actually, may have seen already
back here.
So we design it.
We build it.
We test it.
And we analyze it.
And the analysis--
sometimes when you build it,
you build a large number.
You build a combinatorial set.
So this is something
that's fairly unique
to biological
engineering-- or even
to certain branches of
biological engineering--
that you don't see every
day in civil engineering
or aeronautics.
You don't build a
trillion different 787s
and see which one
works the best.
But you can in biology.
And I'll give you
some examples of that.
And part of the reason
we could do this
is just as there's
next-generation sequencing,
which you've heard
about in this course--
and we were also involved
in next-generation synthesis
and next-generation inserting
synthetic DNA into genomes.
And you'll see all about that.
There are four
different ways of doing
next-generation
synthesis, and it's not
important for this
particular class.
And there are various ways
of doing error correction.
And these are kind of analogous
to the kind of error correction
that you have in electronics
and computational systems,
but we won't stress
that analogy too much.
Here's an example,
just practically,
what you get when you build
these oligonucleotides
on chips.
You might get oligos up
to 300 nucleotides long.
As they get longer, they tend to
accumulate errors a little bit
more towards the end.
And so you can see that with
the length, the number of errors
goes up from 1 in 1,300
raw error rate to 1
in 250 raw error rate.
And then we can get rid
of some of those errors
with a enzymatic system called
ErASE-- it doesn't really
matter in this case.
We can get to 1 in 6,000
without sequencing.
And then with
sequencing, if you're
willing to clone
in sequence, you
can get error rates even lower.
And it's important to know
that fundamental limitation.
You always need to think about
background error in computing
as well as synthesis.
You can now do combined
synthesis and sequencing
very closely by making
cis-regulatory elements, which
we did in this paper that's
published-- Sri Kosuri and Dan
Goodman, in particular-- where
you could basically synthesize
cis-regulatory elements in
the genome or in a plasmid.
And then you could read out the
RNA simply by RNA sequencing.
The number of times you see
this bar code in the RNA
tells you how many times that
particular construct, which
could be heavily
engineered-- it isn't like
randomers-- you're making
interesting, cis-regulatory
elements.
And you can make
10s of thousands
of these-- millions
of these constructs.
We did 10s of thousands.
Then you can measure
protein levels
as a result of cis-regulatory.
So you can have
promoter elements,
ribosome binding sites,
and coding region mutations
that you think might
influence RNA and protein.
And here we do
proteins by having
two fluorescent proteins--
a red and a green.
The red is the control, and it
has a very tight distribution,
as you can see here.
And then the green is subject
to this cis-regulatory mutations
made on chips.
And it has a big distribution.
And you divide it up in a
fluorescence-activated sorter.
And you can read it out.
So here, every pixel on these
two plots for RNA and protein
is a separate experiment.
And you can drill down and
get some more information
on each of these.
But the basic idea is each
of these was individually
synthesized on the chip and
individually sequenced later
to determine.
And the bar codes can be
read out of proportion
to the RNA and
protein expression.
And here's an example of
some surprises that come out
of such studies-- and we're not
just doing this for our health.
So, for example, when
we went into this,
it was well known that
codon usage effect
was correlated with, and could
even causally influence--
so here's an example
of causality--
the expression of a protein.
If you have very commonly
used codons, which typically
have high levels of the
corresponding transfer
RNA in the cell, that the
observation-- and it makes
sense-- is that
those proteins would
be expressed at higher levels.
The thing that was
new was we discovered
that at the end terminus, close
to the cis-regulatory elements,
it flips.
It's the opposite.
There's almost no correlation
with abundant codons,
and there's essentially
a negative correlation
here with an r squared
of 0.73, right here,
that shows that there's a
higher expression with very
rare codons.
This was published in Science.
And so a lot of them
tend to be AT-rich,
but we can separate
out that component.
We can separate out things
like ribosome binding
sites, which are AG-rich.
And there's just a general
trend where rare codons help
expression if they're at
the beginning of the gene.
And you could find that out
from this kind of experiment.
So now we want, if we're going
to build the genome that's
radically different-- let's say
"radically different," here,
defined as 7 to 13 codons,
chains, genome-wide freed up--
liberated-- meaning
that we use the synonyms
in the genetic code.
So there's anywhere
from one to six codons
for each amino acid-- three
codons for stop codons.
We can use that synonymous
substitution table
to move things
around and completely
free up-- get rid of
every instance of a UAG
and turn it into UAA.
That's the first example.
And we did that genome-wide
and thereby derisked it.
We can now build on
top of that, because we
can get genomes that grow well
under a variety of conditions.
They're still
genetically engineerable.
And everywhere
there's a bar there,
this refers to a
successful mutation
in the height of
the bar as refers
to the efficiency of
introducing those mutations.
Now we wanted to derisk another
special category-- remember,
I said AGA and AGG are
special, in that they're
the rarest coding codons.
So UGA is a stop codon.
AGA and AGG are
arginine-encoding codons.
And they're the rarest.
And they also are
complicated, because they
tend to represent
Shine-Dalgarno sites, which
tend to be AG-rich regions
that are involved in initiation
of protein synthesis.
Anyway, so there, the
number was a little large
to do genome-wide, so we
focused on essential genes.
And so you can computationally
find all the essential genes
and design strategies for
getting all the AGG and AGAs.
And then when you
synthesize those genomes,
you can do them one at a
time with a process called
[? MAIDS, ?] which we won't
go into-- too experimental.
But basically, you
can essentially just
go straight from
oligos into the genome,
and you can do multiple
ones simultaneously.
And you can see which
ones are hard to make
and which ones are easy-- again,
that's the sort of efficiency
number there.
You can see which ones-- if
they're selected against.
And some of them were
actually selected against.
We could not find them.
And so these are discoveries.
These are examples where
synonymous is not synonymous.
It could mean that there's
some other function, hidden,
layered on top of
the synonyms-- might
be a ribosome binding site.
And so what we find is
that we can try other,
let's say other arginine
codons, rather than
the one we targeted.
Or you sometimes can
try out other codons
that are not even synonymous.
And eventually we found
every single one of them.
So there were about a dozen.
They were hard at
first, and then
we eventually found an
engineering workaround.
And that illustrates a
number of interesting points.
So those were all successful
in essential genes.
And it's our
observation that if you
get it to work for
essential genes,
getting it to work for
the nonessential genes
is even easier.
So then we went on, and so
that's one codon at a time,
two more at time.
So we've derisked three
codons at this point.
So we went on to derisk all
13 codons-- or 13 of the 64.
And we did that in even
smaller set of genes.
So there are 290 essential
genes in E. coli.
We did 42.
And in that case,
there were 400.
And some examples of those--
and every one of them
worked except for one.
And just like the arginine
codons-- that one,
we tried a number
of different codons,
and they worked-- including
non-synonymous codons.
So in almost every case, you
can find something that works.
And then we do biological
assays that the four functions
that we felt should be
changed were actually changed.
And here's two slides
on the virus resistance.
You can do, in a
variety of ways,
of determining how effective
the virus resistance is.
Here you have about
a factor of 1,000
for phage lambda,
which has been mutated
to be highly
virulent in E. coli.
This is a very pathogenic
version of phage lambda.
This is T7, which is
naturally quite lytic.
And you can show that this is
resistant to two of the three
viruses that we tested.
And our hypothesis is
if we change more codons
than just-- that
was just one codon.
If we change seven or so,
which is what we're doing now,
then it will be resistant
to all viruses--
and very heavily
resistant-- so resistant
that the population
of viruses can't
mutate enough to
become resistant.
So all of you should
be questioning
that-- do I really believe that?
And we can talk about
that in the discussion.
So now the other
big functionality
is-- can we genetically,
metabolically isolate these?
And to do this,
we took advantage
of its new genetic code.
Not only we've
freed up a codon, we
can now make that codon
code for a new amino acid
by another set of biochemistry.
And here's some examples.
The amino acids look kind of
like tyrosine or phenylalanine.
Here's one that's
a biphenylalanine,
so it's got two benzene
rings instead of one.
And so it's bulkier.
It's bulkier than any
other amino acid, any
naturally occurring one.
And we wanted to ask-- can
we make those essential genes
that we've been
talking about-- can we
make them addicted
to this amino acid?
And so we did by this
computational protein design
strategy.
And the idea is we looked
through every crystal structure
of every essential protein in E.
coli-- there's 129 or something
like that, 120
crystal structures--
and systematically
ask, were there
any places where we could
fit in a larger amino acid
by carving away
adjacent amino acids,
such that when we then replace
that larger one with a smaller
one-- still keeping its
surroundings mutated,
so we could mutate it two,
three, four, eight times--
however many amino
acids nearby you
need to accommodate the
big amino acid-- if it
no longer accommodates
the small amino acids?
So you basically
systematically go
through every amino acid
for every crystal structure
and found a short list
of a half dozen or so
that looked promising.
And so the idea is, you put
in these 2-phenol groups--
and now, when you accommodate
it and shrink it down,
it won't work.
OK, that's the basic idea.
And in context,
we wanted to have
a really tough test for this.
We wanted to say, not only do we
want it to be addicted to this,
but we don't want it to be able
to escape-- either by mutation
and evolution, we don't
want it to escape.
We don't want it to
be able to escape
by eating it's fellow-- its
classmates-- its other E. coli.
And so the test
we do is we do a--
did you have a
question, anybody?
We would lyse the cells--
lyse cells of a wild-type E.
coli or certain
mutant strains that
would produce large
amounts of these.
And one of the more classic ways
of making an organism that's
metabolically isolated so it
can't survive in the wild--
it can only survive
in an industrial plant
or in a laboratory--
and we did this
with the classic ones,
which people have avoided
using lysates, because it
gives them bad news, which
is if you grow them on lysates,
you get a lot of survivors.
These are the classic ones.
The deletions of these
two genes makes them--
they will still grow.
But this is an example of one
of our designed, nonstandard
amino acid strains.
And we get much
lower escape rates.
And you'll say, even
this low number here,
we want to get
that down to zero.
And you'll see how
we do that a moment.
This is Mike Mee as
a graduate student.
So here's a close-up of-- this
is not of the active site.
This just could be any
place in the protein
where putting in a big amino
acid is going to be disruptive.
So we change this
leucine, innocent leucine,
that's packed all around
with other amino acids.
Have you guys done protein
design in this class at all?
Yeah?
OK, so you know what
I'm talking about.
Rosetta, right?
OK.
So that's what we're using here.
We had to modify it to use
nonstandard amino acids,
because normally people design
proteins with 20 amino acids.
So we took this leucine--
we made it into this bipA.
And you can see now,
it's got all kinds
of clashes-- three
initial clashes.
That's not good.
So we identify those clashes
and we make them smaller--
no clashes anymore.
This is all done
in the computer.
This is all theoretical.
Can you believe that?
We'll see.
So then-- this is putting
back in a small amino acid.
These are some of the
people that did it.
So Marc and Dan are
post-docs in the lab,
and Ryo and Barry did
the crystallography.
I'm a crystallographer
by training,
but I'm a little
out of practice.
So here is the design again, and
there's the electron density.
So now you can
believe it, right?
Because it's not just
a computer model.
Well, it's still a computer
model, but it's based on data.
And here's a comparison of
the design with the X-ray
structure-- not too shabby.
OK.
But the question is, how well
does this work in living cells?
So these are cells where we've
gone-- changed the whole genome
so that now the stop
codon, UAG, is free.
It's never used, which means
we can delete the release
factor that normally recognizes
a stop codon, which otherwise
would have been lethal.
And we can replace it
with a transfer RNA
in a tRNA synthetase that brings
in this [INAUDIBLE] amino acid.
And now-- this is the one
we were just looking at,
the crystal structure
in bold here.
And it has an escape
frequency which
is higher-- we can
crank up mutagenesis
by putting it in a
mutS minus background.
Basically, one of the
mismatched repair proteins--
we can knock it out, which
increases, sort of accelerates,
evolution.
And it has a noticeable
escape frequency.
So a more realistic scenario
would be this mutS plus.
And we can get escape
frequencies as low as 10
to the minus 8th.
These are for other mutations
in that same protein.
And here are mutations
in another protein.
So then we said, OK, but
none of these are perfect.
We want something that's
undetectable levels of escape.
So how would we, how
would you, fix this?
Anybody?
I'm trying to encourage
you to interrupt me,
so I'm interrupting you.
Anybody?
You've got these things
that are escaping
at very low frequencies.
We should be proud of that.
But we want to
drive it even more.
Rather than 10 to
the minus 8th, you
want get down to 10 to minus
10th, or something like that.
Suggestions?
AUDIENCE: So this is
reversion of the mutations
of the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well, so this means
that you can take the bipA,
and you mutate the codon so it
doesn't encode bipA anymore.
It encodes something else.
So it doesn't need
bipA from the media.
And it puts in another amino
acid, and it somehow survives.
So even though it's
not a perfect fit,
it does well enough
that the enzyme is made.
AUDIENCE: So then modified
multiple essential genes?
PROFESSOR: Multiple
essential genes-- wow.
Couldn't have said
it better myself.
That's what we did.
So before we could choose
which two we wanted
to use-- or three-- we wanted
to know what the spectrum was.
So we forced in all 20
standard amino acids
to replace the bipA.
So we said, let's mutate them
intentionally-- synthetically--
and see what the spectrum is.
Now this is not going to be
the natural spectrum, the sort
of mutagenic spectrum--
this is our intentional--
so what we do is, we
put in each of the 20.
And then we do a quick
selection at 20 doublings.
It's a very fast evolution,
not three billion years.
My students didn't want to wait.
So in 20 doublings,
you get a spectrum
of which amino acids
will substitute for bipA.
In an ideal world,
none of them would.
But we forced them to, and
these are the survivors.
And so the ones we've
been talking about here,
W, tryptofan, is what
we'll substitute for bipA.
And that kind of makes sense.
It's the biggest amino acid.
And that works for
the [? tyrS ?],
which happens to be
the tRNA sythetase.
And then we picked
this other one
under this big red arrow
for AdK-- adenosine kinase--
[INAUDIBLE] kinase--
where there's
very little tryptophan
that will work in that one.
But you get some
escapees if you force
it to take these hydrophobic
aliphatics like leucine.
So we made the double mutant of
the-- we don't have it here--
but we've made the double
mutant of the AdK and the tyrS,
and it's vanishingly small.
We're probably not done.
We'll keep doing this.
But this is the way that
you do a radical recoding
and get new functions.
Any questions on that part?
We're going to move onto
human genome engineering.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
and recognize
the different amino acid.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I skipped
over that because that's
a little more on the
biological, a little less
on the computational side.
So this was a work from Peter
Shultz' lab and other groups.
And what you do is you take a
synthetase that's orthogonal,
meaning it's from a completely
different organism--
in this case,
Methanococcus jannaschii,
which is a hyperthermalphile.
You take that synthetase--
it's about as far as you
can get on the evolutionary
phylogenetic tree-- you bring
it into E. coli.
You bring in its cognate, tRNA.
You change the
anticodon so that it
will recognize UAG, which
is not what typically
any tRNA normally recognizes.
And that only works with
certain synthetases.
So only certain synthetases are
blind to the anticodon-- mainly
serine and leucine
synthetase is in E. coli.
Anyway, so you can now
evolve the active site
that binds to the
amino acid and the ATP.
So the amino acid and
ATP cause the amino acid
to be [INAUDIBLE]
the transfer RNA.
Anyway, you can
change the active site
so that now it
recognizes any amino acid
you want to a first
approximation.
And you could do that
through a combination
of intelligent design
and random mutagenesis,
and there are selections
for that as well.
So in general, if
you're going to be
doing random or
semirandom mutagenesis,
it's always great
to have a selection
so there are selections
for these things.
And there now are
dozens of amino acids
that work fairly well
in that scenario.
The main thing that
was limiting was not
the synthetase-- I mean,
you could get synthetases.
It's the tRNA then had to
compete with the release
factor in the stop codon or had
to compete with another tRNA
if you use a
different anticodon.
And so freeing up this codon
means there's no competition.
And now it works about as
well as a regular amino acid.
But when it has to compete,
it's at a great disadvantage.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can you explain
why changing the genetic code
will cause all virus resistance?
PROFESSOR: I planted that,
but thank you anyway.
So there's a genetic code
up there in circular form--
probably you're more used
to seeing it in rectangular.
But imagine that we've now
derisked this UAG stop codon
and these AGA and AGG codons
here-- R for arginine.
And we're in the process
of putting all those three
codons together with another
four for serine and leucine.
And remember, I said serine
and leucine is interesting,
because you could swap
out the anticodon--
the synthetase doesn't care.
So that's why we picked those
ones-- the three rarest ones,
plus four where you can
swap out the anticodon.
So we could swap serine
and leucine, for example.
So serine and leucine
also are examples of tRNAs
that bind to six
different codons.
So moving two of them
is not a big deal.
So you still got four left.
So anyway, imagine that we
remove them or swap them
and do weird stuff with them.
Every time the
phage comes in, it
has lots of serines and
leucines that are using these,
and arginines and stops.
And every time it wants
to put in a leucine,
the ribosome puts in a serine.
Well, you can note, leucine
and serine aren't that similar,
and that's going to cause a
mess for every single protein it
makes.
And there might be dozens--
maybe even hundreds
for big phage-- of those codons.
And so you can do the math--
that the chance of mutating
one of those codons to something
that will work is fairly high.
Two is squared, three
to the n power, where
n is the number of
changes it has to make.
And so if you make
enough changes,
population sizes have to
become astronomical in order
to contain one member that
has changed all of its codons
the right way and
hasn't changed a bunch
of codons that would be lethal.
AUDIENCE: So the ones
that you chose, were they
the rarest of the codons--
PROFESSOR: So the first
three were the rarest.
And part of that
is because we felt
we would run into the
most trouble there.
They may be rare for a reason.
And we wanted to
discover those reasons,
both for biological
curiosity, but also
to derisk the
subsequent engineering.
But the leucine and
serine ones are normal.
They're not that rare.
But we derisked them.
And remember that one
where we did 13 codons
on 42 essential genes?
That's how we showed
that, in general, it's
not toxic to individual genes.
But there are examples of
things where you derisk it
on individual genes and you
start making lots of them,
and then you get so-called
"synthetic lethals"
where various pairs
of genes conspire.
But so far, most of
the deleterious nature
of the genomes-- where the
genomes are a little bit slower
growing-- it's usually due
to hitchhiker mutations,
not due to our design-- except
in cases where it's completely
not working, in
which case we have
to find an alternative codon.
But we have to deal
with all these things--
design errors, biological
discovery, and hitchhikers.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: If you've
already found
that multiple, simultaneous
mutations is unlikely,
works, if they all had
happened at the same time,
but if you have this
engineered system, if you
have some way of migrating
code to other-- you
could end up with the spreading
of your non-secret codes
so that you can mutate
things, one of them at a time,
and accumulate.
PROFESSOR: Well, so,
first of all, a phage
doesn't carry
along its own code.
If it did, we could preempt
that by making lethal genes--
that if you bring in the
tRNA that has the old code,
you activate the lethal gene.
But I think you were
talking about more
a Darwinian
perspective, where you
have incremental changes
that allow you to slog along
well enough that you
can get more mutations.
The problem is, this
collection of mutations--
there is no growth.
Every protein is
majorly messed up.
And so you're not talking about,
say, antibiotic resistance,
where there will be kind of
a gradient of antibiotics.
And somewhere on the
edge of the gradient,
there will be just enough
antibiotic to be selective,
but not enough to kill it.
This is something where, the
instant they get into the cell,
there's no gradient.
They only have one code choice,
and that code is something--
I think the difference between
this and regular evolution
is, regular evolution-- if the
bacteria tried this strategy,
it would be changing
a little bit at a time
and the phage be
keeping up with it.
But we took it offline, so to
speak, did major code revision,
and moved it back.
And the phage was not watching.
And the phage isn't as
intelligent as hackers are.
OK, any other questions?
We could stay on this topic.
We don't have to
go on to humans.
OK, just for fun let's
go on to human genome.
How many people here want
to have their genome edited?
All right.
We'll ask in just a moment
what you want to have changed.
So these are some of the
tools that my colleagues and I
have worked on.
I've been doing this
most of my career,
is coming up with new tools
for engineering genomes
and sequencing genomes.
And the one I've been
talking about so far
is down here at the bottom--
is Rec A and Red Beta.
And the star for going
forward is this Cas9 protein.
But we color-coded them here
so that the recognition--
the critical thing
about genome editing
is finding the needle
in the haystack.
You want to change
one base pair.
You don't want to
change anything else.
And so something has
to do that recognition.
That recognition
can be Watson-Crick,
so you can have
DNA-DNA-- searching
through the entire genome
with DNA-DNA interactions,
or RNA-DNA interactions,
or Watson-Crick,
or protein-DNA
interactions, which
I'm sure you've learned
about quite a bit.
And so we have examples of
each of these-- two examples
are RNA, in blue; two examples
of DNA, down in the box;
and then all the
rest are protein,
where the protein-- the
amino acid side chains
are recognizing, typically,
some kind of alpha
helix in the major groove.
OK, so Cas9 was
something that was
a nice case of computational
biology, in my opinion.
It was found in 1987 in E.
coli by Ishino and colleagues.
And it was essentially junk DNA.
It was not conserved.
It was repetitive,
which were two
of the hallmarks
of junk DNA, which
were very popular
talk about in 1987.
They were trying to shut
down the Genome Project
before it started, three
years before it started--
before the NIH part of it
started-- because they didn't
want to sequence anything
in the human genome that
wasn't coding for proteins.
I'm serious.
So anyway, this languished
as junk DNA for many years.
It eventually became
clear to the cognoscenti
bacteriologists that it might
be an interesting, adaptive
immunity-- kind of
like antibodies--
rather than the fixed or
native immunity, which
were restriction enzymes.
So this is kind of the adaptive
version of restriction enzymes.
But it still didn't
really catch on
until 2013, when a
couple of my post-docs
and ex-post-doc and
graduate students in January
got it to work in
humans-- so moved it
from bacteria to humans--
kind of a big jump.
And then it became
surprisingly easy,
once it made that jump, to get
it to work in every organism
that we and others have tried.
So now 20 different
organisms, at least,
that this works in-- fungi,
plants, and even elephants.
We haven't published
the elephant yet,
but we have our
reasons for doing that.
And the most frequently asked
question-- and this, of course,
should appeal to computational
biologists trying
to do design-- is,
what about off-target?
And it turns out now there
are many ways of dealing
with off-target-- so much
so that I would be so bold--
and this is a
slight speculation--
but I would say we're
currently at the point
where it's almost not
measurable, the off-target.
And these are the different
ways you can do it.
So we started out,
in our January 2013,
with theoretical, where
you would basically
look for-- anybody in this
room would know immediately
how to do this-- would look
for potential off-targets that
are off by one or
two nucleotides
and ban those from
consideration.
And then you take a shorter
list and do an empirical search,
because this is so inexpensive.
Basically, you
have this guide RNA
which is making a triple helix.
It's binding the one
strand of the DNA.
It's so easy to make
those guide RNAs.
It's just 20 nucleotides
you have to make.
You pop it into a vector
where everything else
is taken care of.
It's so easy to do that that
you can make a lot of them,
and you do an empirical search.
You find places that
are particularly
hot for the right sites and very
cold for the wrong off-targets.
So those are the
first two methods.
Then paired nickases--
they don't make
a double-strand
break, which is what
it does out of the
box from nature.
It makes a double-strand break.
You have it make a
single-strand nick.
Then you require two of these
to be coincident and near one
another.
It's like the concept of PCR.
You have to have two primers
that are near one another.
So it's a coincidence.
So it's like a p squared--
if the probability is
one is off by one or two
or however many it takes,
the chances of getting two
such sites near each other
is roughly p squared.
Truncated guide RNA
is not something
that you would necessarily guess
that, if you make the guide RNA
smaller, it's
going to be better.
But there's obviously
some optimum.
If you make it too long, then
it can bind by any subset--
any kind of mismatched subset.
If you make it too short, then
from informatics standpoint,
it doesn't have enough
bits to recognize
a place in the genome.
So it turned out that
the optimal length
was a little bit different
from the natural length.
It was about two shorter.
And finally-- and
this just came out.
And this is from Keith
Joung and David Liu's lab,
where you get rid of the
beautiful, double-strand break
capacity.
You can turn into
a nickase, or you
can make it completely
nonfunctinal as a nucleus
and then add nucleus
domains back.
And you say, well, it
seems kind of bizarre
that you're doing all that
work-- that you get rid
of the nucleus and
you add it back--
add in a different one, the
FokI bacterial restriction
in the nucleus.
But it turns out this
is the way that people
have taken other DNA-binding
proteins-- the zinc
fingers and then
the tau proteins.
And so it had to be tried,
and it works extremely well.
And it's like the
paired nickases--
you need two of these sites
in order to get cleavage.
And stay tuned.
I'm sure there's more.
So I just want to close on
this idea of causality again.
I opened on it.
I'll close on it.
Here's an example of a
double null-- myostatin
double null, as the both
maternal and paternal copies
are missing.
There are a lot of
examples of double nulls.
We could talk about some later.
And they're often rare.
So at one point, there
was only one person
in the world that was
characterized with this.
And it's hard to do a
large cohort study on this.
And they weren't really sick.
The phenotype-- this little
baby had heavy musculature,
as if he was working out next
to Arnold Schwarzenegger.
But he came out this way,
and he stayed that way.
But it's striking.
You look at the
genome and you say,
wow-- a double null and a
highly conserved protein.
That's got to mean something.
And then you can
have a hypothesis
of what it means based on what
was known about that pathway.
And it coincides
with the phenotype.
And so you have a
strong hypothesis,
and you can test it in animals.
And so here, you
don't normally test it
in three different
animal species.
But this one, there happened to
be either preexisting or easy
tests in cows, dogs, and mice.
So that's one thing you
can do to get a causality.
And the other
thing is, there are
cases where the animal
models don't work.
Either you knew in
advance they weren't
going to work because they
don't have that brain structure.
There's nothing
other than humans
that have a particular
kind of brain structure,
so it's hard to make mutants,
because you're already
a mutant.
And so another option is
organs on chips or organoids,
because they're not really
fully physiologically faithful.
And this, at least, is human,
but just like animal models
can have artifacts,
human organoids
can have artifacts as well.
Here's an example
of something that
will be coming out in a few
days that we did together
with Keith Parker's
lab and Bill Pu's lab.
And I think this
is a nice example
of where you can take a
hypothesis, where one base here
is changed-- this G
right here, is deleted--
and that's putatively what
causes this cardiomyopathy that
affects mitochondrial function.
And you can mutate that
using the CRISPR technology
I was talking about, where
you use homologous remedies
to go in, find that
one base, change it.
Or you can just make
a mess near there.
So one control is
to not change it,
and the other control is to put
a little insertion, deletion
in there.
And of course that
messes it up as well.
And so you've now constructed
three isogenic strains.
These are actually my cells.
In the Personal Genome Project,
we take volunteers like myself
and establish stem cell lines.
And then from the
stem cell lines,
we can establish, in this
case, very well-ordered
cardiac tissue we'll
see in the next slide.
And that cardiac tissue, you
can test for lipid biochemistry,
for other physiological
parameters,
for the morphology and
the contractility-- so
diastole and systole that you
get in the cardiac muscle.
So you basically make
something where you've only
changed one base
pair in my genome,
and we've made, essentially,
a version of me that's mutant.
Unfortunately, I don't think
I had the picture of that.
I thought I did.
Oh, there it is.
So here's an
example-- how you get
this beautiful, ribbon-like
striated pattern
that you expect
of cardiac muscle.
This is programmed from
my fibroblast turned
into stem cells into muscle.
And then if you introduce
the two mutations--
either the one that corresponds
to a patient or one that's just
a mess-- you get a
morphological mess.
And then you can restore those
by putting in the messenger
RNA that will cover
for the mutation.
So I'm going to open it up
for questions at that point.
That's causality-- I think.
Questions?
While we're waiting,
anybody wants
to volunteer what
they would like
to change about themselves?
You can mention a
specific base pair or kind
of a general idea of what
you'd like to change,
whether you think there's any
safety considerations that we
should keep in mind.
AUDIENCE: The problem's
delivery, right?
That's the--
PROFESSOR: Delivery.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, fair enough.
So gene therapy had a crack.
People were a
little overanxious,
a little overambitious
about over a decade ago.
And a small number of
patients died from cancers,
because there was
random integration.
Rather than this precise
genome manipulation
we're talking about
here, there was
kind of random
lentiviral integration
of extra copies of genes.
And if you land in
the wrong place,
then your lentiviral
or retroviral promoter
will go off into
oncogenes, like LMO2.
So that delivery
was viral delivery,
and it was random integration.
We now have delivery
mechanisms that
are nonintegrative or
integrative in a specific place
or, in this case, can make
precise base pair changes.
So there's two
levels of delivery--
one is to get it to
the right tissue,
and the other is to get
it to the right base pair.
I think both are
semisolved problems.
So you can do ex vivo delivery.
So you can take T
cells out of a body.
You can use a previous
generation-- the zinc finger
nucleus-- to cleave both
copies of the CCR5 gene.
And now people that
had full-blown AIDS,
you put these T cells
back in their body,
and then now they're
AIDS resistant.
Those T cells that have
both copies of the CCR5 gene
missing, which is the AIDS
coreceptor, are now resistant.
So that's ex vivo.
That's one way to do it.
Delivery to the
liver is quite easy.
You can do that with
nonviral vectors,
and a [INAUDIBLE] virus is
one that's very popular.
You can get it to go to
almost every cell in the body,
either selectively or generally.
So you just want to make
sure that once it goes there,
it doesn't cause any
damage other than the base
pair you want to change.
So there are now 2,000
gene therapy trials
in phase one, two, and three.
It's a big change
from a decade ago,
where I think people had pretty
much given up on gene therapy.
There's now 2,000
clinical trials.
And one has emerged all
the way out of phase three
into full approval in Europe.
Ironically, they now have
genetically engineered humans
in a land where they don't eat
genetically modified foods.
But I think they're
better for it So far, it's
curing diseases.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: For your
noncanonical amino acids,
does this open up
enzymatic reactions that
would be, say,
impossible, do you think,
with if you add a new amino
acid that can [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: So I'll just repeat
the question for our viewing
audience.
Do nonstandard amino acids open
up new enzymatic reactions?
And there's already a couple
of examples in the literature.
This was done prior to this
wonderful strain, where
there's no competition.
It was done at low efficiency.
But putting in one amino
acid at low efficiency-- you
could still get an enzyme.
So even if it's,
like, 10% efficiency,
you produce 10 times as
much enzyme, and it works.
So there were some
redox-coumarin derivatives
of amino acids.
So coumarin-redox
capabilities is not
present in any of the
other amino acids.
And they took a protein that
was very well studied-- where
they had by protein design,
and by random mutagenesis,
and they threw the book
at it-- and they could not
budge the activity beyond
the apparently optimal,
naturally occurring activity.
They put in this amino
acid, which was not randomly
chosen-- it was a redox-coumarin
derivative-- they put it
in the active site.
I think they tried out a
few different things that
made a small
combinatorial library.
But the point is, they
got a tenfold improvement
in the catalytic rate constants.
So that's an example.
Another example, which
isn't really catalytic,
but it's very popular, is that
you can put in polyethylene
glycol-modified amino
acids wherever you want
rather than kind of randomly.
You can put it in precisely.
And this will greatly
extend the serum half-life,
so that normal proteins like
human growth hormone, which
is a approved pharmaceutical
for certain uses--
not all the uses that you find
on the internet, but other
uses-- but it turns over
very quickly in the serum.
And so if you put a polyethylene
glycol in the right place
on human growth hormone--
or other human protein
pharmaceuticals--
they last longer.
Those are two examples-- one
of them definitely active site.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: This is
actually a small detail
from your [INAUDIBLE]
study, where
you looked at the structure and
mutated one of the amino acids
to this phenyl
thing, and then you
changed a bunch of
other amino acids
to compensate for that size.
So I noticed most of the changes
were to either [INAUDIBLE],
but one of them
was a tryptophan.
So why was that?
PROFESSOR: Let's
go back to that,
and see if we can find that.
AUDIENCE: It was
a previous slide.
Yeah, this one.
So it was amino acid 271.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, OK.
So in each of these lines--
I didn't spend much time
on this-- in each
of these lines,
there's one amino acid
we've changed to bipA.
So these three are
all the same protein,
and it's all the same
mutation-- leucine 303 to bipA.
And then all the other
ones are compensating.
And then here, you can see
it's a different leucine
and a different protein.
They're all leucines--
different proteins.
Now what's your question about?
AUDIENCE: My question
was the compensating
mutations are generally all
the smaller amino acids, right?
PROFESSOR: Oh, I see.
So why phenylalanine
and tryptophan?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Well, those
are pretty close.
So these are done by
energy, not by eyeball.
They're done all by
COMP ROSETTA, where
we combinatorially go
through lots of side chains.
So we combinatorially
went through lots
of proteins, lots of positions
to substitute amino acid,
then lots of accommodating
mutations-- which
is not necessarily the typical
way you use this software.
Anyway, that probably
is some stacking
of one of the two aromatic
rings onto the tryptophan.
Yeah.
And we tried many combinations.
No doubt, we tried
the phenylalanine
and the tryptophan in
various combinations
with the other ones, and
the tryptophan empirically
works better.
MODERATOR: Are there
any more questions?